so I always ask the question to Bernie
Sanders supporters do you trust the
government and almost always they say no
no the government's bought by lobbyists
and corporations and by the war machine
say why that earth would you wanna make
that government bigger it goes without
saying conservatism and more importantly
conservatives have had few places to
turn on college campus so where does
that leave young conservative students
in 2012 a determined 18 year old kid
named Charlie Kirk took it upon himself
to answer that question his answer
Turning Point USA an organization whose
mission is to educate train and organize
students through their campus chapters
in yearly event over the past eight
years
Charlie has grown TP USA's reach to over
fifteen hundred campuses throughout the
nation in 2016 Charlie joined then
candidate Donald Trump's campaign and
he's been a steadfast supporter of the
president ever since his newest book is
the Magna Doctrine the only ideas that
will win the future
in our conversation Charlie and I dive
headfirst into whether President Trump
has been good for the conservative
movement what it will take for
Republicans to hold the White House as
well as why the same Democratic
candidate he hopes will face President
Trump in 2020 is also the one it
terrifies him most
[Music]
welcome this is the Ben Shapiro show
Sunday special Charley Kirk is joining
us today now just a reminder we'll be
doing some bonus questions with Charlie
the only way to get access to that part
of the conversation is to become a
member head on over to daily wear DICOM
become a member you'll have access to
all of the full conversations with every
one of our awesome guests
Charlie thanks so much for joining us
and I just wanna make it clear from the
very outset that it appears the Charlie
and I are an equal I level there is an
Apple box for president trunk there's
there's an Apple box there's a ladder
and I'm on stilts that's the only way or
if you aren't able to actually yes we
see eye to eye here yeah now we're on
the same we'll see if we see eye to eye
throughout the whole conversation I
think we might okay so why don't we
start with your background for people
who only know you from the memes and
know this will be meme above like just
make them clear you're free to use this
however you want in terms of memes
people okay now we've opened the gate so
Charlie I met you when you were but an
even younger whippersnapper you're only
26 now but I think I met you and you
were maybe 18 years older like a
horowitz freedom retreat retreat and you
were just starting Turning Point USA so
at 18 years old you you didn't go to
college so how did you how did you
decide number one not going to college
number two gonna do student activism and
number three gonna start one of the
largest student organizations in the
country well thank you Ben it's an honor
to be here I appreciate it all very much
started it I had no money no connections
no idea what I was doing I always had a
passion for politics and for saving the
country and I was I grew up in the
suburbs of Chicago I originally wanted
to go to West Point didn't get in ended
up being the best thing that never
happened to me I convinced my parents to
allow me to take a gap year before
entering college and one gap year has
now turned into eight gap years and the
great irony the whole thing is I run an
organization that's focused on college
campus outreach that actually go into
college myself but it's now you know on
2,000 high school and college campuses
you spoke at our last event which was
down in Palm Beach at the end of last
year and and look you know this you
visit a lot of campuses across the
country it's it there's a crisis
happening right now in higher education
where students are being taught to hate
our country where anti Americanism is on
the rise and I think conservative values
and conservative ideas are being given
an opportunity to really have a revival
and a renaissance and you know we see
that a turning point USA we see that the
work that we're doing in the speeches
that I give and the visits that you know
I partake in and it's been a great
journey over the last eight years and
it's been fun
seeing of course you when I first met
you you were you know working and
writing and doing radio and then of
course that was before the Daily wire
and not seeing that kind of take off so
it's been fun kind of you know
throughout the last couple years you
know kind of see them both both entities
grow so what is your relationship like
with President Trump my mother personal
and a business like that's what that's
what people kind of want to know sure
because that the picture of you in
public because I've knew you before
Trump was Trump I mean he was Trump but
he just wasn't in the political mix
nearly as much as obviously he is now I
knew you as conservative college campus
guy most people now know you as kind of
Trump guy online who does Trump e things
so how did you what is your relationship
whatever and that that's fair I wouldn't
say that's the extent of everything I do
but that's definitely how you know
people will stop and say hey you know
the president don't you like yeah yeah I
do look he's been extraordinary to me
and you know I'm very candid and upfront
with it he's been very good to me
personally his family's been really good
to me
I met Don jr. in the summer 2016 after I
spoke at the Republican National
Convention I felt you know our country
was you get to go in a horrible
direction of Hillary Clinton got elected
president originally I was a Ted Cruz
supporter and then you know then
endorsed Trump as you know he was the
nominee because that was what a lot of
people did including Mike Pence who as a
Cruz than Trump guy and I went I went up
the Donald Trump jr. and I said look we
need to do something with students and
youth infrastructure I have a couple
years of experience under my belt I
would love to travel with you across the
country and maybe organize some student
events and he was his willingness to do
that was unusual in politics usually you
have to go through a hierarchy and there
really wasn't much of a hierarchy in the
Trump campaign in those days back in
July and August 2:16 obviously the
surprising election happened and kind of
it was stunning for a lot of different
people and you know the president you
know I developed a pretty good
relationship with him and he's been he's
been extraordinary in a lot of different
ways he's delivered results for our
country the likes of which I wouldn't
have even predicted you know for the
conservative agenda and for you know the
the American revitalization agenda and
you know spending time with him has been
a real thrill for someone that you know
never went to college and started this
organization on a whim to be able to you
know meet with the president at States
and be able to you know inform oh the
other things we're doing on college
campuses has been you know really
exciting and an immense blessing in many
different ways so
how do you bridge the gap between sort
of what you do on college campuses and
your activity with President Trump what
I mean by that is that by looking at
polls president Trump's wildly unpopular
with young people right this is the one
area where he is probably most unpopular
just in terms of the polling data now
conservatism is never supremely popular
with with young people particularly
people on campus a president Trump seems
to have raised a particularly loved ire
with people 18 to 21 at the same time
you're running this major campus
organization he has people who love Mon
campus no question yes there are people
who just adore him I know man where the
maggots
Tibet right shower in the class no
matter what then there's a fervent base
for him a hundred percent so what do you
think the mission of TP USA is and how
does that combined with sort of what
President Trump does and where it puts
you guys in the position of maximizing
the conservative movement when on the
one hand it gets ya sort of super
passion on the other hand Trump is such
an alienating name for people who are
young on get it's a it's a great
question and look so there's positive
and negatives in any you know presidency
when it comes to college campus outreach
and the positives has been it's opened a
huge amount of enthusiasm and interest
on college campuses where we have
thousands of students attending our
events lots of opposition that comes and
you know that that makes the events far
more you know exciting and you know with
a lot more energy than it otherwise
would have been I I have a I have an
seven eight year window I can say from
the moment that President Trump got
elected college campus activism from
Turning Point USA side
doubled tripled quadrupled almost
overnight and it emboldened college
conservatives to stand for conservative
principles even more so pre Trump and
now mind you I've been doing this for a
couple decades so my reference point
it's only about eight years but I could
tell you that the MIT Romney Republican
Party we would not have kids that were
doing what they are today where they're
starting students for Trump groups at UC
Berkeley or University of California
Irvine and I think that's one of the
positives of the Trump presidency is
that conservatives are less afraid than
ever before to say what they believe in
the stand with conviction and you know
the president has definitely I think
taught us that you can punch back twice
as hard to use a Barack Obama expression
that you know you use quite often and I
think that's one of the great positives
of the Trump presidency and him as an
individual is that you have to recognize
that the left is a destructive force in
our country and I think new
which says it best if president Trump's
ideology can be best summed up he's an
anti leftist presidency right and I
agreed them and I think that though if
you recognize the left in media culture
Hollywood and academia as a corrosive
force to our culture in our country and
you'd make them the enemy and we're
going to put them as in opposition I
think there that's been very very
helpful to us as an organization
fighting on the ground in college
campuses so what do you do with the
folks who are in the middle and
convinced of also as I say the Trump is
phenomenal in firing up mame you see it
is rallies you see it up didn't you see
it online I mean the the his base is
fired up and this is because as you say
Trump is uniquely aggressive he is as I
said during the campaign in 2016 a
hammer in search of a nail it's
extraordinarily satisfying when he hits
a nail it is not as satisfying when he
hits a kitten but with that said when
when it comes to you know what's
happening on college campuses how do you
reach out and have you had any success
reaching out to people who are wavering
or is it more along the lines of
emboldened in people who are quiet
before yeah come forward there's a lot
of that I'd love to get you know your
feedback because you go to these
campuses too and you get a lot of you
know different questions and from from
people and there are people that come to
the front of the line and ask questions
you'll say charlie I like what you say I
like the ideas just I'm not there yet on
Trump and my perspective on that is look
I believe it I believe you know I'm
gonna defend the president and his
agenda and what he's done for our
country and more times than not students
will say okay I might not agree with all
that but I appreciate the fervency that
you support him with and you explain it
better than most people would and and
that's that's the position that we take
and I think the moveable middle if you
will has become more winnable than ever
before because of the Marxist insurgency
in the Democrat Party and I think that
it's presenting a huge opportunity for
people like you and people like me to
make convincing arguments for
conservative ideas now I will say though
that the traditional conservative
outreach on college campuses let's say
the last 40 or 50 years we're just
talking about corporate tax cuts and
just talking about the same sort of
macroeconomic issues it wasn't always
there wasn't always doing the job on
campuses what Trump has liberated though
is more cultural issues as well where
he's saying you know maybe English
should be the official language of the
United States we're gonna talk about
immigration we're going to talk about
culture and there are a lot of young
people that are deeply passionate about
these issues just outside of you know
the discussions about GDP growth which I
care about a lot I mean of course I want
a robust free market economy
but I think the Trump presidency and
Trump in general him weighing into
different cultural issues I think has
also opened the door for us to win over
a lot of young people otherwise might
not be registered and not haven't been
voting at all in the first place because
you spend so much time and kind of
defending from do you ever feel the
necessity on campus do you separate
yourself off from things that maybe does
wrong because obviously he's a human
being like anybody else he's got his
foibles some may say more than others at
least in public life so when you're on
campus yeah and and somebody asks you a
question about something that Trump has
done that you know of what you don't
approve do you ever feel the necessity
to defend it look I don't agree with
everything he's done no person would we
always would agree that everything
anyone ever does right but I don't go
out of my way to criticize him and I'm
very I'm very upfront about that and I I
don't consider that to be my role and I
don't consider that to be helpful at all
to the threat that we're facing up
against dominant Marxism and leftism in
our country in our culture and you know
I might disagree on this where I think
my particular role right now is that
there are not enough people doing a
full-throated defense of the trump
presidency an administration especially
on college campuses where it is so
unusual for someone to come and say no
president Trump might be one of the most
successful presidents in modern American
history and in students will say they're
so puzzled and flummoxed if somebody
says that and then I'll start to recite
some some facts and some statistics that
they might not have heard and economic
success Louis ever black unemployment
Hispanic unemployment Asian unemployment
energy-independent the things that you
know you and I know just offed
off-the-cuff that students might not
hear but look I don't agree with
everything that he's done from a policy
perspective or position I agreed almost
all of it though because a lot of it and
you've talked about this is traditional
conservative stuff his stuff that we've
talked about you know in the
conservative circles for the last couple
decades things that people have promised
and never delivered upon like energy
independence like moving the embassy to
Jerusalem like deregulating the economy
like cutting taxes these sorts of things
are traditional conservative free market
ideas that have been you know tossed
around for quite some time but I make
the argument in the book as well why did
it take Trump to actually do this like
why did george w bush ever speak at the
march for life
why didn't Joe HW Bush ever moved the
Embassy of Jerusalem why didn't your job
you Bush recognized the Golan Heights
why was it Trump the billionaire
businessman from New York who was a
recent you know conservative who at one
point in his life held a pro-choice
position why would
Keigo and defund Planned Parenthood
funding and I make the argument it's
because this is the populism at its best
it's because the conservative movement
and the America the people in America
have supported him hold these positions
and he promised to fulfill what he said
he was gonna run on and actually for
doing that as a president I think is so
is so in my opinion unusual and
something that deserves praise I mean
there's no question then that his
willingness to violate long-held
conventional wisdom
it definitely has his ups eyes I mean
people tend to focus a lot on the
downsides you know the Twitter account
and the and the insults and all that
kind of stuff but the truth is in policy
terms very often he will he will stumble
upon a conventional wisdom it'll say
this makes no sense
it'll just completely overturn it and
turns out the conventional wisdom was
absolutely wrong and that definitely is
one of the strengths of his presidency
when he has done that yeah and look I'll
give like three examples China is one of
them you know from from a pure
theoretical position I'm not a fan of
tariffs if we just talk about
macroeconomics tariffs or taxes however
from a national security position I'm a
huge fan of tariffs on China because I
think China's our greatest enemy
geopolitically and otherwise I and you
look at what China has done building
islands in the South China Sea hacking
our cyber grid basically sending spies
from the CCP on Confucius Institute
college campuses president Trump
basically threw up the entire chessboard
on China and said no this entire way
we've been viewing China has been
incorrect immigration is another example
two Republican and Democrat presidents
both alike from HW Bush on have just
kind of had this Agreement not really
solidify the southern border and just to
allow unlimited amounts of green cards
to be issued he had an unorthodox
position on that and also culture as
well Republican presidents have passed
they did not challenge the media like
President Trump has and I think that's
been a very positive of this presidency
because the media right now is worse
than I was as I've ever seen it I mean
they're an activist Network for the
Democrat Party they really are and they
go out of their way to misrepresent
positions and to attack conservative
values so one of the things that I've
objected to is the conflation of anti
leftism
with conservatism and I think that
you're rightly distinguishing the two
but I think that we should be even
clearer about the distinction so it's
true that President Trump is I agree the
most anti left president of the modern
American era there there's I mean this
is what he campaigned on I mean it
there's a reason that Rush Limbaugh in
the middle of the 2016 campaign
rechristened the
advanced the the Institute for Advanced
conservative studies to the Institute
for Advanced anti left his studies
really sort of as an homage to President
Trump that comes along with some some
rewards and it comes along with some
risks the the roared is that it makes
very clear who the opposition is which
is something that Republicans
conservatives traditionally have not
done I'm all for it I think that
clarification grew necessary the the
risk is that anti left is broader than
conservative and suddenly you may be
associating with people who oppose the
left but who also are not only not
conservative but opposed a lot of the
ideals of conservatism or you may be
willing to overlook in the in the simple
binary battle you may be over willing to
overlook activity that you that is not
conservative in the name of anti leftism
so this is where you get into president
Trump's heresies bad things that he has
said in the past bad things that he is
that he has done the the fact that
nobody in the Republican Party seems to
give a damn about spending anymore I'm
old enough to remember when we all cared
about spending but this entire
completely on this yeah and now
obviously we are blowing out the
spending to an extraordinary extent and
so and if you criticize that then you
are accused of being an aid to the left
because you are opposing a principle
that is a principle of the left but
because Trump is anti left then it's the
the enemy of my enemy is my friends sort
of thing so where do you draw the line
between forward and conservatism and
forwarding anti leftist it's a great
question I try to answer that question
in the book where I said what is the
doctrine of the Trump presidency you
know the Munroe had the doctor dr.
Monroe Doctrine I call it the Magid
doctrine which the argument I make is
that it's a blend of conservatism
populism common sense and a pro-american
approach and I look back to the Reagan
era and we had eight years of awesome
conservative wins under Ronald Reagan
and HW Bush undid a lot of those HW Bush
grew the size of government he put back
bureaucrats that Ronald Reagan fired and
all of a sudden we kind of saw a descent
away from Ronald Reagan conservatism and
really remember Reagan was a populist -
I mean Reagan was both a conservative
and a populist and I think there's
dangers to populism and it's for this
extent but I don't think that we as
conservatives should be afraid of it I I
think that there's a lot of positives
when it comes to listening to the people
and actually bringing dignity back to
forgotten America and so what is the
doctrine of the Trump presidency I make
the argument that it's analyzing every
decision and every deeply held belief in
Washington DC by the rule
class so the wise men of Washington and
asking the question objectively has this
been serving our country well and then
if no what is the proper approach to it
and by using that kind of common-sense
approach he's actually come organically
to conservative positions that other
people that ran on conservative
positions would not have organically
come to such as standing for life we've
we've been to the list canceling the
Iran deal getting out of the getting out
of TPP getting out of the Paris climate
Accord these are things that traditional
conservatives might not have actually
had the backbone to do that and it's a
question I get a lot like what is he Act
what is the actual belief system what is
the philosophy well what he's trying to
do is really hard which is to try to
recover and renew a country that was
almost and managed to climb by a
bipartisan big government consensus and
a globalist consensus under kind of the
bush Clinton Obama years which was
alright you know Georgia Abbey Bush
would be more will get corporate tax
cuts would kind of keep the borders open
and we're going to be more hawkish on
foreign policy Obama exact opposite were
going to send billions of dollars to the
evil Iranian 's still keep the borders
open we're gonna have any Indian become
an economic growth I make the argument
the the doctrine that he espouses and
that he believes in is when we can learn
from we should advance for the next you
know couple decades and hopefully the
next century which is are we actually
seeing that are we actually seeing
results for the people that he ran to
represent and it seems as if we had a
ruling class party sent you know post
Reagan and Donald Trump I believe has
positively disrupted that one of the
questions that I have about ideas like
the Maginot Rijn is are we trying to in
flesh a skeleton that can be in flesh in
a number of different ways meaning what
we're trying to well yeah President
Trump has as I've said this before so
this is no great secret I think that he
has excellent political instincts I
think that he also has spasms of thought
I don't think he has a comprehensive
worldview in any serious way I mean this
is not someone who sits around he is a
businessman he doesn't sit around
reading Milton Friedman he's openly brag
about having read written more books
than his read and so trying to sort of
graft a broad ideological agenda on to
that as opposed to I think common sense
is a fairly good description of how he
sees his own agenda
but trying to graft on an ideology I
mean Tucker's tried Tucker Carlson has
tried to graft on one particular
ideology
you've seen I think Jared Kushner try to
graft on a different ideology I think it
seemed Penn's tried
I found a different ideology and it
seems like there's this constant
exercise going on in which there is sort
of a skeleton of feelings and instincts
that is good and then everybody tries to
put a stress put flesh on it and
sometimes it looks like a line and
sometimes it looks like a chicken and
it's not super clear so what exactly it
is I see you're coming here I'll
disagree slightly I think his doctrine
first and foremost is from the first
time he announced for the presidency he
said through instinctual observance to
where the country was going is we're not
winning anymore and there's something
deeply wrong with who's been running our
country and how they've been running our
country and his agenda his doctrine and
those people you mentioned have all
placed more I would say political
philosophy behind it but let's take a
step before that is how are we going to
renew and revitalize the country how are
we gonna bring this back to a place of
excellence and it goes back to a phrase
that you and I believe and the left does
not believe Bernie Sanders does not
believe this Nancy Pelosi does not
believe this that were the greatest
country ever to exist in the history of
the world it's the idea of American
exceptionalism I know he believes that
that for sure and that's why I picked
that picture he's lugging a flag right
and and that's his agenda it's like I
care about this like I care about my son
or I care about a beloved and and
sometimes he's going to you know engage
in braggadocio or he's gonna you know do
things that are off the wall and
atypical and we've there's been
unlimited coverage of all that however
he goes back to a default position of
I've been elected by forgotten America
because a lot of people showed up for
the first time in a long time people
switched parties and people and I think
there's something to that to bring
dignity to those parts of the country
that have been disenfranchised by the
ruling class because our country was
taken advantage of for so long and it's
a it's a blend of nationalism populism
conservatism and that weren't those two
words common sense I think make I think
that frames it up really well and it's
also it's challenging the ruling class
consensus and I think there's some I
think there's a lot of there's a lot of
truth to that which is have these people
been right about what they've been
feeding us the last 30 or 40 years maybe
got certain things and by other things
maybe not and especially when it comes
to these these positions such as oh why
we should never challenge China like
really that's that's it seems like both
parties have just been kind of okay with
allowing the rise to China with a couple
senators here and there that have been
speaking out
President Trump has opened and has given
oxygen now to a an American America
first agenda towards China that I think
will benefit you know our generation for
generations to come so to answer your
question I think the doctrine if you
will is that I love my country so much I
believe it's a gift that's been given to
us I'm gonna do whatever it takes to try
to save it and revitalize it I can't say
that about Bernie Sanders his agenda is
this place's this mistake it's a racist
country it's bigoted it's backwards and
I want to revolutionize it and turn it
in this some sort of Marxist Western
European failed nanny state so in a
second I want to ask you about one of
the biggest questions I often get on
college campuses I'm sure you get it a
lot to which is how much of this is just
Trump doing stuff and how much of it is
for DHS we'll get to that in just one
second but first let's talk about a sad
reality you're bad at predicting the
future not just you like all the humans
because if people were great at
predicting the future you just go to
Vegas and you'd be rich and then you
wouldn't need life insurance but here's
the thing you do need life insurance
unpredictability keeps life interesting
and makes it nerve-racking
one way to worry less about the future
is to get the rifle life insurance
policy this is where policy genius can
help policy genius makes finding the
right life insurance a breeze in minutes
you can compare quotes from the top
insurers and find the best price you can
save 1,500 bucks or more a year by using
policy genius to compare life insurance
policies once you apply the policy
genius team handles all the paperwork
and the red tape for free and policy
genius doesn't just make life insurance
easy they can also help you find the
right home auto insurance disability
insurance they can help you do the
bundling the whole deal so if you
haven't found a play-by-play a breakdown
of your future inside a crystal ball or
a fortune cookie
that's okay be prepared for anything
with life insurance in just a few
minutes you can find your best price and
apply over at policy genius.com
also just be a responsible human being
god forbid something should happen to
your family will be without your income
you don't need that but you do need his
life insurance policy genius will always
get the future wrong better to get life
insurance right okay so let's talk about
how President Trump is perceived so I
think one of the critiques that some
people make view particularly is that is
that maybe you're giving the president
too much credit on on his sort of how
much of this is plan so I for example
love a lot of the policies that you just
talked about I also happen to think the
politics is much more veep than house of
cards and I think that everyone is
basically a
and so when the president says things
that appear to me to be not brilliant I
won't say that appears to me to be
brilliant that I think that's kind of
dumb uh you've been criticized for sort
of the 40 chest model of thinking of
President Trump that President Trump is
thinking three steps ahead that when he
says a thing about Colin Kaepernick
kneeling for the national anthem he's
not doing that because it's just a gut
instinct that he's tweeting out but
because he's actually thought through
the ramifications of whatever it is he
said that may not be a fair
characterization of you but how do you
think about I I don't necessarily think
it's a fair characterization but it's
fair to say I get that actor yeah
exactly let's say that I will say from
from my time spending a time around him
and seeing him be able to predict things
correctly for example he said I'm being
spied on people laughed at it remember
he said that tweet out during transition
actually turned out that there was a lot
of nonsense and the whole FISA process
that he was being spied on
I think his instincts are terrific and
one of the in the book and otherwise is
that he does have 40 years of built-up
experience in a wide variety of
different endeavors from pop culture to
television to building buildings to the
woman rank that does make him a very
unique individual to be able to be to
address this multitude of problems and
these issues and so I asked myself the
question so is it in people's trash
themselves question to like is it
instinct or is it just kind of flying
blind as he just you know hitting things
in the dark
I believe it's instinct because if it
was just flying by in the dark why was
it that other Republican presidents that
we've seen the last 30 years were able
to do what he's been able to do and have
the courage and the conviction to be
able to do this I'll give you some
examples of this why did it take
President Trump to renegotiate and after
the USMC a which is great for our
country bipartisan consensus big credit
to Jared Kushner and his team that
worked really hard on it
why did it take president Trump to be
able to get you know to get the VA
accountability act on or get right to
try and I make the argument that he's
not afraid to push boundaries of kind of
the bureaucratic consensus in DC where
they'll they'll give him no for an
answer and a traditional politician that
was born in bread and politics in the US
Senate will probably take that more
seriously and he's he's unafraid because
of his experience and because of where
he's been and how and who he is to say
what do you see what he's saying no what
do you mean by that and he's not afraid
to push those boundaries I think that's
a healthy thing for our country and one
of the things that frustrates me the
most about critics of President Trump
and
and you in no way you know it embodied
us at all but people on the Left do this
they think everything he does comes from
a sinister Machiavellian perspective
said this directly to Bill Maher Bill
Maher was saying this to me and I was
like well which is it is he is he an
idiot or is he an evil genius you're
gonna have to pay you stood up for it
wonderfully now I have to give you
credit for that because it's nonsense
it's like wait so he gets some sort of
weird pleasure for kids being locked up
in cages even though that was under
Barack Obama right it's like it's either
you have to you have to can't just
alternate it's either that he's playing
for DHS and he's you know a Bond villain
or he's just has no idea what he's doing
because you can't you can't be one one
day in one the other I come from the
perspective that his motives are pure
and his motives are good that he does
deeply care about this country he really
does and he gets when he gets the most
upset he gets the most angry is when our
country gets taken advantage of when he
sees bad deals being brokered or he sees
us going in a direction that will make
us less competitive for future
generations to come and I talk about
quite often you look at the rallies
these rallies that we've seen him do
they're an act they're a political
phenomenon we've never seen presidents a
year and a half from election be able to
draw 35,000 40,000 people when you go to
these rallies and I encourage people to
do it there's something really unusual
that happens that very few people are on
their phones texting they're locked into
him and it kind of struck me after the
fourth or fifth or sixth rally I went to
I said they look at him as their vessel
back to representative government and it
might it might not be as you know as
let's just say as pure and simple as
that but I think it works because
there's a lot of people millions tens of
millions people in this country that
have felt disenfranchised by just the
traditional political class and they see
in him in the most unusual way you
couldn't have predicted it or wrote it a
brash billionaire from New York City
that has given more voice to the working
class in this country then you know then
I would say just a traditional u.s.
senator from some of these Midwestern
states and some of the states that I
think have quite honestly at the expense
of the ruling class agenda have seen
their lives not not necessarily progress
in a way that they saw fit so going into
the 2020 cycle I've seen a couple of
different sort of defenses and possible
defenses of the trump presidency pushed
forward in terms of advertising there's
one that I think is less successful and
one that I think is more successful I'd
like to get a take on them you know one
that I think is less successful is the
tack the president is a magnificent
trait who knows exactly what he's doing
he's fully in control of everything and
everything is swell because of all those
things the other one is the ad that his
campaign cut which i think is an
excellent dad where he said you may not
like him you may not like its labels you
may not like all the things he tweets
but do you like your wallet how do I go
in for you and I think that that is a
more successful approach to Trump so I
wonder how you feel about that because
do you think that it's it's off-putting
to people the overt defense of somebody
who I mean people make their own
decisions about Trump it's not like when
you say Trump's a wonderful guy I know
him personally we get along great we go
fishing together the people all of a
sudden you don't know I can't see
president from fishing to be honest with
you but it but with that said yeah I
wonder you know when you make the
character defense yes of Trump that
seems like a much harder defensive Trump
because people have their own it might
be I make it because it's truth is I'd
make it because it's true I don't make
it because it might be easier or harder
I will say though the easier argument to
make is to say kasam Soleimani would be
alive if it did I ain't that guy the
United States is right like that
I mean you like Gorsuch and Cavanaugh
because they wouldn't be on the Supreme
Court if you had a Democrat or even a
different type of Republican and I think
the ad that the campaign cut to your
excellent point he might be the tough
guy but he's a tough guy we need he's
rough around there basically the ad and
I'm not putting words in their mouth it
was he might be rough around the edges
but we need that fighter now I think
making the street brawler argument can
resonate with a lot of people because
what you're doing it's an old salesman
trick right you take the criticism off
the table immediately right so people
might they look at the ad they're like
oh yeah I kind of agree at that because
that is a deep that's a belief that
people have or they're like I like what
he does I might not like his style and
you hear it a lot and I hear it a lot
and but if you take that off from
branding his presidency or branding his
his message and you say wait a second
you look at what he's done maybe there's
maybe all those things that you consider
a negative the the brawler the street
fighter maybe our country's needed a
street fighter for some time I think
that is a an effective effective way to
brand it but also saying the left has
gone so off the rails especially when it
comes to just things that should stop at
the water's edge I mean a Soloman
anything really bothers me because this
guy's a maniac
and he deserved to die he was a
terrorist and if Pete Buddha judges the
nominee low likelihood that happens
right he basically said yeah Salah money
would still be alive that I mean fur for
a family
Florida that's wondering who to vote for
that's a pretty stark contrast that like
Kasim Salamone would be alive or not
alive a guy that killed you know better
than I five hundred six hundred
Americans you know in the Iraq war and
so I think there I think that kind of
binary choice does it does a lot and I
think the president is gonna be really
hard to run up against because I think
he gets more popular more binary the
race becomes because politics is a
binary choice it's not a referendum
ideas it's not do you want this water
reclamation district or not right it's
it's do you want Bernie Sanders or do
you want President Trump or do you want
Bloomberg do what President Trump and I
think of some of those matchups all of a
sudden President Trump becomes a lot
more appealing to a lot more people so
there's maybe a moot point because
President Trump has not been supremely
malleable to criticisms of his excesses
but they're kind of two perspectives
about about dealing with with President
Trump that we've seen inside the
administration and outside one is the
let Trump be Trump view well just let
him free unchain the man let him let him
run through the the china store he's
bullying trying to shop but we need the
ball and then there is the the
perspective
well let's critique him where it's
possible let's try to convince him let's
try to talk him down
obviously look I've been of the the
second view this has been perfectly
obvious I think that he's been hemmed in
by his advisors on a wide variety of
occasions in which has been quite good
for him to listen to his advisers yeah
where do you come down on the Twitter is
a good example like I'm of the view and
I think a lot of people in and out of
the administration of the view would be
wonderful they have one person read his
tweets before he had said just like one
guy it doesn't matter just like the
secretary down the hall just let the
janitor like somebody read the tweets
before he hit Send and then there were
people who say no no I would inhibit him
that would that would stop him we've
seen this break into the open well
relatively recently with regards to
Attorney General bar who's like can you
just stop tweeting about the cases I'm
handling here you're undercutting me in
terms like well I know I'm undercutting
you but whatever man like I got man's
gotta be who demands gotta be your
though so so look I'm gonna make an
argument that will be a little kind of
atypical
so which is there are people in this
country when you go to these mega
rallies you go to i/o you go to Ohio
they love the tweets they do for sure
and there is a population out there and
I don't interface with them every single
day I interface with them you know more
than most and they love it and there is
a point to this no and a common
criticism I get and part of the rise of
Bernie Sanders is the authenticity
argument oh yeah that Marxism stuff I'm
not really a fan of it you know like the
fact that our country
he's gonna burn but he really seems like
he knows what he is who he is I would
make the argument that if President
Trump became too political became to DC
and became too vanilla he would lose a
lot of his visits overestimated maybe
I'm overcompensating at mei'm him over
had handicapping it but there are people
that are pleased that he's the same
person that he was on the escalator
today he's turned down like a spinal tap
11 down to like a - but like 11 28.5 Hey
look none of us will know the balance of
how much you get and how much you lose I
will say this though that he does
command the news cycle better than any
other president we've ever seen and and
there there have been high-level quality
social media tweets and trolling of the
left the likes of which is gonna be
legendary in the halls of internet
culture seriously though and if he's
going up against the left or that kind
of fervency and sometimes say oh maybe
you shouldn't have tweeted this I say no
no no he recognizes the threat to this
country that goes back to the anti
leftist thing right and Dennis Prager
makes this argument quite often which is
if you run and you recognize it of
course they will not be stopped unless
they come up against someone willing to
punch them back twice as hard and I
think President Trump is that man for
the moment and you know I get a common
criticism from people they say well
Charlie you're a Christian how could you
support this right how could you do this
I say and you might appreciate this well
then we got to take Samson out of the
Hall of faith I mean Samson was a man
who in a prostitute's bed God came to
him and revealed to say basically you
got what I need you to go fight the
Philistines and with a java donkey he
you know killed a thousand Philistines I
can't teach that in Sunday school right
that's pretty brutal
I would make the argument that Trump for
lack of a better term was called for a
moment like this to be that brutal
street fighter that we really need it
and if if if it's if it's indelicate and
if it's not you know right down the
fairway so be it
because there's an enemy there's not
position to a blessing that God gave us
that is this country that is in need of
that kind of street fighter I mean my
only critique of that would be it would
still be better if Samson and up and
shtupping the prostitute no I'm not I'm
not defending it I'm not trust me but
you can't dismiss the argument I mean in
Hebrews 14 for he's in the Hall of faith
right Coenen court hall of fame yeah
right and he had his own moral
indiscretions we all do right there's
different extremes they're different
variations
Lila I mean let's I'm you're saying
there's different but you know in the
Bible you and I both you know consider
it to be the Holy Word of God right and
Sam I'm not ripping on Sam's no I'm not
I'm not accusing you that right I'm just
saying that's an instance of someone who
was flawed multiple times right and we
see that but he was called for a
specific fights a specific fight to
bring God's people against an opposition
which the Philistines and to fight
pretty brutally and now that's I'm using
that more metaphorically a president
Trump's gonna take up donkey you know
Java donkey in for Media Matters
Charlie's not calling for President
Trump to slay a thousand no National
Committee staff right I'm not I'm not
sure I'm not saying that at all but you
honor the the analogy is that sometimes
God calls impure unusual people to go
fight for righteous causes so let's
let's talk about one more thing with
regard to the anti-life things so again
anti left all for it left is tears we
love them I love that is it but one
thing that that worries me about the the
anti left attitude as opposed to the
conservative attitude and I think that
you need both right conservatism is anti
left because it's conservative not just
because anti left is anti left is
something that you've come up against
and that is a a gatekeeper problem so
there are a lot of people who consider
themselves anti left who also happen to
believe it's Rochas leo things yeah and
you and I have both denounced them
publicly and events and all that right
so where does the why where's the line
from between what is appropriate
behavior infighting left and what is
inappropriate behavior in in fighting
the left great question that's where
morals come in right that's where we
have to say we don't believe you don't
believe this and I don't believe this
one race is better than the other I
don't believe that America should be by
any means a any sort of exercise in a
racial majoritarian experiment that's
not who we are it never has been I mean
the phrase a pluribus unum is part of
the American Trinity e pluribus unum In
God We Trust and liberty and so here's
where I make the argument in the mega
doctrine and so you have conservative
values incorporated anti leftism and
populism right but let's take it to a
further extent which is we and president
Trump has denounced the hatred he has
denounced the vile you know
insidious nonsense that is out there and
he has and he's he's gotten more
forceful and he's gotten
or ahead of it as time has gone on
because unfortunately their their
minority of a minority but they're out
there and they have real hatred for
certain individuals and I'm not gonna
say any names but that's just how it is
and I go on college campus sometimes I
get questions that are horrible about
Jewish individuals you know and horrible
horrible things and I denounce them and
I fight back against it however that's
where it comes in to our moral position
and our conservative position of the
belief in the American Trinity but if
you take it to a further extent right if
we're nothing but just conservatism on a
chalkboard right and we're nothing but
just always saying we're in a free trade
if everyone always well what's the
extent of that right so the the inverse
would be what what if we take the other
too far and we make we allow the rise of
China to be too much and I can make the
argument that HW Bush and Clinton so on
and so forth allowed that other extreme
that happened and so that's where I
think President Trump has balanced it I
really do we have the healthy dose of
anti leftism populism and conservatism
however when that hatred comes up and it
rears its ugly head we have a moral
obligation as conservatives to kick out
the demons in our own ranks and it's
something the left will never do they
never ever exercise the demons in their
own ranks in fact they embrace them one
of the areas where you've obviously come
under a lot of criticism on campus is
from this specific group that we're
talking about this has become ya
headline where the issue when they tried
to do the same thing to Donald from jr.
and kimberly guilfoyle and they've been
approaching on campus and these specific
criticisms aside from the sort of just
plain racism of it seem to be that
you're too socially liberal so what is
your what is your perspective on well
look I mean I I believe merit is one man
one woman I believe in biblical marriage
I always have and I also have people
that are gay on my staff and I'm not
afraid to share the stage with people
that are gay other individuals think and
they have said this that gay people do
not have a position in the conservative
movement I believe that is wrong
I believe that Dave Rubin and Peter teal
and Tammy Bruce have a place in the
conservative movement I absolutely do
and I think that I I think it's so
backwards that they would believe that
we should somehow grow the influence the
conservative movement by the process of
subtraction of people that are turned
off by the left turn up I woke culture
of the left
somehow they believe that the
conservative
that should be closing its doors to
people that all of a sudden might be
I'll be interested in your podcast or
your your position or your speeches I
March at the March for Life I am very
very pro-life against Planned Parenthood
it's an unfair accusation against me it
justice but I'm also I won't apologize
for happening having people that are gay
on my staff sharing the stage of people
that are gay that have served our
country and that our veterans it's not
something I'm going to apologize for a
second for and it doesn't compromise my
Christianity my moral positions on
marriage or my conservative beliefs okay
the other critique they've been hitting
you with is that you're supposedly too
soft on immigration so on and give you a
chance to response respond to their
charge that you are some sort of open
borders guys again I appreciate you
actually bringing it up because I can
clear the air on it it's nonsense
I said something let's just say I said a
position that I wreak Lera fide where I
should have said it more stringently but
I believe in less legal and illegal
immigration I support Senator Tom
Cotton's act where essentially he wants
to limit the amount of green cards to
500,000 a year I mean I have been
defending ice facilities up against ice
protesters building the wall deporting
illegal aliens making English the
official language of the United States
again it's an unfair accusation and I
will agree with the with the fervency
that I think immigration is one of the
top issues in America I really do
however if your drive for that
immigration policy is bit rooted in
hatred of another group in position or
in racial supremacy that's wrong if it's
from a position that well our country's
being taken advantage of and it's and
it's we can't afford or take a million
green cards every single year that's a
cuts of conversation I can have that's
what I actually sympathize with and I
agree with and I think we should have
less legal and illegal immigration but
again the accusation is unfair through
through okay so in one second I want to
ask you about the other side of the
island and talk about the left and
Bernie Sanders but first let's talk
about why you should protect your data
on the internet so you wouldn't like go
home open up your safe open up your
front door and then just think to
yourself that humanity is filled with
wonderful people so why would you unlock
your internet activity did you know that
your internet service provider knows
every single website you visit which is
super creepy and of course they can then
sell that information to tech giant's
expressvpn puts a stop to all of this it
creates a secure in
to tunnel between your device and the
internet so that your online activity
can't be seen by anyone expressvpn works
on everything phones laptops routers
everyone who shares your Wi-Fi can still
be protected even if they don't even
have express VPN and the best part is
using Express VPN is as easy as closing
the bathroom door you install it on your
computer it runs in the background of
your computer and now you don't have to
worry about it ever again if you don't
use a VPN and your data and browsing
history are taken from you that's sort
of on you considering how easy it is to
get expressvpn so just go do it
be responsible take care of your own
data if you're like me and you believe
your online activity is your business
secure yourself today by visiting
expressvpn comm /ban use my exclusive
link expr ESS @ VPN comm slash man and
you can get next for three months for
free
that's expressvpn comm slash been ok so
let's talk about the other movement that
you've been dealing with on campus and
that of course is the bernie sanders
movement you know young people
particularly are resonating to Bernie
Sanders almost as a council reaction to
trump in some ways but kind of separate
and apart from so bernie is wildly
popular on campus - what do you
attribute the vast bout of insanity
happening on our cup yeah it's a great
question I mean look it's very easy to
be generous other people's money it's
very easy to want to spend other
people's resources and look from a very
basic position if you've never been
taught that our country's a gift or a
blessing why would you want to conserve
that blessing I mean if you've been
taught hatred of our country that were
racist bigoted homophobic backwards then
why not have a revolution against it and
Bernie Sanders he embodies the same
college professor that's been screaming
at them since they first got this
college he's a legitimate Marxist the
honeymoon in the Soviet Union and your
your critique of Bernie Sanders is one
of the best in the entire movement and
you ask the very simple question do you
believe private properties are right
senator Sanders and that's a question
that any honest journalist should ask
him he's a legitimate property
confiscated that's what he is he
believes he does not believe that
individuals have a right given them by
God to own property he does not believe
that he believed its state first human
being second he's a Rizzo and Marxist is
what he is and so look young students
and young people they some of them truly
believe that garbage they really do not
all the Bernie Sanders people do they
actually think that he's on the side of
freedom or Liberty and some sort of
distorted
bizarre concoction they think that he's
actually the fighter and the crusader
for liberty and nothing could be further
from the truth so I always asked
question to Bernie Sanders supporters do
you trust the government and almost
always they say no no the government's
bought by lobbyists and corporations and
by the war machine you know all this
stuff
I say why that earth would you wanna
make that government bigger and they had
no response of course but that's the
whole kind of summation of how I think
you approached senator sanders marks it
you know marxist that our support
senator sanders which is his whole
position his whole worldview is getting
more people more bureaucrats and more
power to the very government you say you
distrust it seems pretty obvious that
president Trump would prefer senator
Sanders as the nominee of the Democratic
may be against him the reason I say that
is because he obviously has been sort of
trying to via his Twitter account stir
up chaos inside the Democratic Party
which is quite good at by targeting
everybody except for Sanders and
suggesting to Sanders supporters that
they're going to be robbed of the
nomination but apparently by the
Democratic upper echelon it seems that
the number ones you agreed that
characterization that that's what Trump
wants maybe I don't know I wouldn't I
wouldn't say it full-throated though
because I've seen President Trump you
know in interviews and time I spent with
him have a good amount of hesitancy by
saying oh yeah all in let's run against
Bernie I think Bernie could beat Trump I
think it's really hard to run against
free and I think the media would go all
out for him especially the younger
journalists Marxist activists class
they'd be more excited than ever to try
to paint him as the salvation that
America needs Bloomberg or Bernie who
would Hollywood go all-in more for I
think Bernie for sure I think I don't
know how much currency that has in
Wisconsin but it could make some impact
probably from a philosophical choice I
would much rather run against Bernie
because I think he embodies actually
with the Democrat parties trying to do
but it terrifies me it terrifies me
because anyone could win right and I you
and I agree that this any major party
nominee could could conceivably be the
president learned that the hard way and
2016 after I lost $10,000 betting
against the president so there you have
it well yeah and so in you because you
start from it you start from a baseline
basically forty to forty two percent
right I mean that's just that's just the
way it is locked were college you're not
running for president in LA County so
it's not gonna happen are you not
running for president Manhattan and so
Bernie Sanders could become president
United States that should horrify
everyone listening to this or watching
this he's a true committed Marxist he
does not love our country
he just doesn't he is on a mission
to radically redefine and deconstruct
our country from within you know the
school of deconstructionism it basically
is the whole whole school of thought is
create cultural chaos everywhere and
that will give rise to an authoritarian
Marxist to allow them to create
something that will eventually not work
at all but give a lot of power to the
ruling class to try to create some
failed come you know communist communal
state I mean it does seem like Sanders
should be the one that Trump is rooting
for in the sense that President Trump is
a wrecking ball man and that is his that
is a specialty I've always said about
about politics the politics is the art
of making it very difficult to vote for
your opponent and making it very easy to
vote for you and president Trump may not
be really popular at the ladder but he's
phenomenal at the former making it very
difficult for people to vote for his
opponents that is that man special well
and I have to say you know in a Super
Bowl interview with Sean Hannity
president Trump comes right out of the
gate and says why did he you in
honeymoon in Russia I was like yes
he's already on that I mean that's a
great critique though I mean why did he
honeymoon in the Soviet Union it would
take on a traditional Republican like
months of work shopping and poll testing
a president Trump this comes right at it
yeah Bernie Sanders honeymoon in the
Soviet Union and and I agree with you me
he's one of the best attack dogs in
American political history I wouldn't
want to run against him no one would I
mean he would be he's relentless he's a
monster
and and not only is he in a good way no
well when it comes to beating people up
he is he's incredible at it he also has
the advantage of every piece of dirt
that could ever be thrown and somebody
has been thrown at him I've described
him as a mud monster in the sense that
no matter how much mud you throw on him
he just looks like mud I mean like he's
already made of mud at this point so
nothing that you throw on him is
actually gonna make a difference where's
Bernie's never actually been vetted by
the media which is unbelievable he's
been useless octogenarian communists for
60 years I mean who's 80 when he was 20
he wasn't just a useless communist when
he was 20 was an octogenarian when he
was 20 and now he's running for
president and nobody has asked him a
simple question hey the other night when
when Michael Bloomberg finally asked him
a question about his lake house and
Bernie had never been asked a question
that's right as lake house him is
perfectly obvious that no one had ever
just asked him straight to his face
about the fact that he's a millionaire
with a lake house and nobody else on the
stage had on it and he didn't have an
answer for it and I just thought to
myself Donald Trump is going to drive to
Bernie Sanders his lake house pry up a
floorboard and figuratively beat him to
death with it
that's right on a public City you know
what he'll do
he'll say this is not even that nice of
a house he'll say he said it Batman
Bernardino say like I'm playing he's
like wait a second fat this is this is
news not even that good he's like I
would have built it better cheaper and
quicker and better on television even
and by the way by mocking it that way it
would get 10 times more visibility be
the front page of the New York Times
president President Trump says Bernie
Sanders third home is not well built by
doing that more people would actually
know about his lake house and and and
look I I have to say that Sanders I
think he's actually in a position he
didn't think he would be in III can be I
he's more focused on his revolution and
his movement than becoming president
I don't think eight nine months ago he
thought he'd be in this position it just
so happens Elizabeth Warren is so
unbelievably bad at politics like really
really bad I mean she lies about
everything about her heritage about her
father being a janitor or something
working-class everything and she's part
of the ruling class professor and she's
just seems like she's always scolding
people and it was kind of the default
position of the angry Marxist in the
Democrat Party like yeah I guess we
still got Bernie he's still screaming
about it right you know
sure and because of that he's he has a
great grass roots rump you know he's a
great grassroots base he's going to win
I think he's gonna win states like
California and Texas I just do and he
probably will be the nominee and people
say well you know they're gonna try to
steal it from him I think that's a
harder bet I think it's actually more
it's more likely he's gonna be the
nominee than they try to steal it from
him that's my perspective yeah I agree I
think that as long as he wins a
plurality of the delegates it's almost
impossible to stake it away for that's
right because he's gonna walk out of
that convention and he'll just say to
his people
listen I'll campaign for the nominee but
they're all gonna stay home I mean
they're all gonna stay home and and
Michael Bloomberg's bizarre bet that if
they gets the convention and he has the
second most delegates that he's gonna be
able to walk in with his giant bag of
cash plopping on Tom Perez his desk and
say I'll spend five billion dollars on
the selection of just throw Bernie out I
can't see Tom Perez taking that deal
because the the press is just too bad
well well yeah again if you look at the
numbers and this is very a this is a
flawed way to look at primaries like oh
yeah this person drops out and all their
votes is gonna go somewhere else it
doesn't work that way it could work a
little bit that way the best the best
fit though is Warren and Bernie like if
Warren drops out they're not going to
Michael Bloomberg anything right like to
her whole shtick that 10% that she has
is
billionaires are bad Marxism but a
little bit lighter touch than Bernie
Sanders and her decay a fuel and her
decline will fuel the rise of Bernie
Sanders and I mean maybe there might be
a Bloomberg go to judge reliance that
could be formed but they're not angry
enough to be the nominee I mean they
want Kathy Griffin Colin Kaepernick's
style anger that's who they are I mean
they want tear it all down Donald Trump
is the worst president American history
this country is horrible and we're gonna
take it back okay great
get 80% of the votes in LA County and
have fun losing Wisconsin do you think
the president has a good shot of winning
in the popular vote this time last time
yeah so that that would be the question
right and I admit it as a trump
supporter yeah I think he might lose the
popular vote worse this time than in
2016 and thank goodness for the
electoral college we and the electoral
college is brilliant it's important to
safeguard of our Republic we're not a
democracy we are a republic huge
difference and I don't think that the
coastal elite cities dominated by Malibu
in Manhattan should dictate our
elections in fact I can make an argument
you have to go to a more diverse pocket
to the country to win the presidency on
the electoral system so I don't think
he'll win the popular vote nor should
you try so basically all resources into
Wisconsin Pennsylvania Michigan's him
Ellie that like all resources into five
or six counties in those states I mean
you're talking about West Milwaukee
I think the black vote could have a huge
impact I really do and especially if
they nominate you know Bloomberg or
Budaj edge which again I think is
unlikely but I still think against
senator Bernie Sanders I think that I
think black Americans and Jared Kushner
and his team deserve a lot of credit for
this have delivered a lot of results for
black America that otherwise would not
have been delivered criminal justice
reform Opportunity Zones low sever black
unemployment do I think he'll win 50%
that's probably unlikely but 15 or 20
percent I think is conceivable okay so
let's look at the second term of Trump
administration so what does that look
like because we've seen basically no
plans I mean he guy he got the the tax
cuts done presumably he moves to make
those permanent and he's done the judges
and presumably there will be more there
there'll be more vacancies and he'll
fill the vacancies but we haven't really
seen from president Trump what are his
plans for a second term because that
Republican agenda unfortunately has
become extraordinarily short right
because it's spending cuts are very
unpopular yeah the president has
basically pledged that there will be
done he's pledged that for a long time
is that he's not going to cut Social
Security or Medicare or
Medicaid the budget that he proposed
proposed some future cuts to futures to
future increases what what is the agenda
really look what's it it's a phenomenal
question it really is because second
terms can be second terms can be really
tricky the second term in george w bush
was a disaster it just was it was
mismanaged there was no clear vision and
from what I hear it gives me confidence
though is that the White House is
getting to a place where it's working as
well as it ever has and I could tell you
that from from Jared Kushner to people
that are back in the White House that
are not spying and leaking on the
President of the United States where you
have disloyal people that are writing
you know writing books and trying to
counter him I don't like any of that I
think it's nonsense I think it's garbage
I think that you serve the president
who's a vessel the American people
you're not there to try to leak or to
try to get earn goodwill with
journalists so I have confidence that in
the second term of this presidency that
you're gonna have a better working
functional White House and you did in
the beginning stages of the first term
but you need some really big agenda
items and if I were to kind of my wish
list I would agree with you size and
scope of government and government
spending we've got to get back to the
Tea Party movement of deficit hawks I a
just have to we have to have harsh
government spending and we've got to get
this under control because you and I are
both can either experience
hyperinflation or anemic economic growth
or uncompetitive 'no sif we don't get
our spending under control and that's
what it originally got me fired up about
barack obama was the amount of debt and
I know President Trump has submitted
budgets that you know do have some
spending cuts but Congress is not taking
them seriously at all
and I think Mick Mulvaney being in the
White House is a positive thing because
he is a deficit Hawk and he has a debt
Hawk the second thing is immigration if
we do not build the southern wall and
start deporting foreign nationals that
are in our country we're gonna be in a
lot of trouble I really believe that and
this whole idea of comprehensive
immigration reform that that's a talking
point I think of the left and the soft
right just to try to get amnesty for a
bunch of people so they can vote for
Democrats in the future so I don't know
how you're gonna work with Congress on
that but that's gonna be somehow to be
addressed I think the third issue is
taking other tech companies that doesn't
mean that has to be a huge amount of
regulation I don't know what it looks
like but there's if I have to say the
top one of the top issues in the
conservative base is censorship and is
the tech companies just acting as if
there are total authoritarians in our
country and I'm hesitant for government
regulation as a free-market guy actually
think regulation could help the very
people that I'm critiquing more than not
it actually be a shield for
monopolies but he has to do something
about that in his second term
okay so looking forward beyond Trump and
I know that that's nearly impossible
because Trump is not only the lodestar
of sort of all politics right now the
gravitational center he's he's the black
hole of all media attention everything
not only revolves around but it's sucked
into it and and so it's hard to foresee
a future in which President Trump either
is not president or is not sort of the
directing force in the Republican Party
but you're 26 yeah president Trump is
held 74 so he's getting up there I mean
he the man should live long and prosper
you'll be alive longer than president
Trump barring you being hit by a car or
an early case of terminal cancer so with
that being the case beyond 2024 what
does the Republican Party look like
because there are these really I think
large internation wars that are being
glossed over and papered over by the
fact that there is a Republican in the
White House yeah and it's going to it's
going to surface sooner rather than
later
and that's part of why I wrote the book
is what is the doctrine what does the
future look like you're starting to see
it right now between common good
conservatism and right based
conservatism and I actually genuinely
see both sides of the arguments and I
depends on the issue I sympathize with
one side over the other all depending on
it but that's going to be a huge huge
debate going into the future and what is
the fee I think that one couple things
that the Republican Party or the
conservative movement can take away from
President Trump which is take the
populist that you represent really
really seriously don't ignore issues
that might be politically incorrect that
are harming people's lives like
immigration or trade ever again and
those are things I talk about in this
book that he ran on that the Republican
Party was like oh yeah we're just gonna
kind of get along on these issues a
president Trump ran on less immigrants
you know stricter border control and
renegotiated trade deals I don't want
the Republican Party to go back to be
the party the ruling class I don't want
a party of Mitt Romney I don't I don't
let the party of Lake Champlain on Labor
Day like that bothers me where it's just
an elitist party where it's just the
same people circulating the same sort of
elitist talking points I want to be the
party to people that shower before work
and shower after work I want to be the
party where labor unions think the
Republican Party stands for them too and
you can get disagreements on how labor
unions raise the cost and I think
there's some validity of that but
totally disenfranchising labor in our
country I think was a big mistake and
President Trump I think proved that I
don't want to be the party of the
her feller Romney Bush you know kind of
philosophy and I think those those
arguments are gonna play itself out
tremendously and I think that we're
rights based conservatism has really
really good points which is you only got
one gun you make this point right don't
ever do anything with this gun you don't
want someone in the left to do awesome
point we're common good conservatives
make the point which is we have a disc
lining culture and country right now and
people that are really suffering why are
we not doing more to help them right
here right now
both have validity they're gonna play
itself out and I think it's gonna be I
think it's going to be pretty pretty
pretty heated to be perfectly honest
with you and to your point president
trumping the anti leftist president has
kind of kept all that at bay but post
Trump whatever that looks like if he
gets reelected
January of 2021 you are gonna have a
jump ball he's a basketball analogy the
likes of which the conservative movement
has not seen since a time for choosing
speech Ronald Reagan fact that he gave
at the convention so I do want to ask
you one final question early and that is
what your plans are like what are you
planning to do over the next 15 or 20
years is again you're 26 years old but
if you want to hear Charlie's final
question then you have to go over to
Daley wire comm when you do and when you
go subscribe then you will get the rest
of our conversation over there now be
sure to go pick up your copy of the
maggin because it has gold lettering on
it and a picture of the president
hugging the flag so it is an exercise
not only in brilliance but subtlety
I mean clearly Charlie thanks appreciate
it
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro shows Sunday special is
directed by Mike Joyner and produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring associate producer Katie Swinton
post-production is supervised by Alex's
Singaram editing is by Jim nickel audio
is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and makeup
is by Anika Geneva title graphics are by
Cynthia and Guillot the Ben Shapiro
shows Sunday special is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
[Music]